thousands evacuated but hundreds still
left behind searching questions for the
government about how they are now
brought to safety we have broken faith
with them if if we now don't move as the
prime minister said heaven and earth to
get them out we have we have made a
commitment and we now need a discussion
with the taliban and pakistan and other
neighbors to get them out and back to
the uk that's what we've promised
one interpreter who worked with western
forces but couldn't leave spoke
anonymously to sky news and said he now
feared for his life
trades before have been
fear about my life if i've been stuck
here
for longer
they could easily
stress me and they can easily find me
they know my i know some of them because
you know my full identity my uh
details they have where i live where i
work
so
still i don't know what would
happen so as the inquest begins in
westminster how did it get to this as
well as broader concerns about the uk's
strategy in afghanistan a blame game has
also erupted here about the evacuation
process with anonymous briefings blaming
the foreign office for a lack of
preparedness and whistleblower claims
about thousands of emails relating to
afghan refugees that allegedly went
unanswered
labour mps say they struggled to get
clear information or timely responses
for constituents who needed help with
family members stuck in afghanistan
they've had 18 months to plan for this
whilst they may not have expected kabul
to fall so quickly they knew that the
end of the forces presence was coming
they knew what date that was they should
have been planning that from the 31st of
august for the last 18 months what was
going to happen then by when
visiting the government crisis center
with the prime minister last week
foreign secretary dominic raab was
already under pressure over a holiday he
took while kabul fell
some now suspect dirty tricks an attempt
to frame one department for any failures
of the last fortnight the foreign office
says it deployed a 24 7 operation to
deal with cases but has always been
clear that not everyone would get out
there's concern on the conservative
benches too though there's been a litany
of concerns that absolutely need to be
addressed and uh errors that have been
made as well simply because there isn't
the bandwidth to be able to cope with
challenges such as this and we need to
recognize uh that this is a wake-up call
that the world is getting more dangerous
not less
as the final planes carrying troops from
afghanistan touched down today a new
more distant relationship for the uk
begins but one still riddled with
political complexity and danger rob
powell sky news in westminster